خارج إيران، في أي مكان آخر
تتطلع قطر إلى تقديم خدمات الوساطة الخاصة بها،
نحن في كل مكان،
لذا أعني أنني سأعطيكم بعض
الأمثلة، لدينا اهتمام متجدد بأن
نكون وسيطًا دوليًا، كما
تعلمون أننا نفخر بأنفسنا  لكوننا
شريكًا دوليًا موثوقًا به، فقد
عملنا على عدد لا يحصى من القضايا في الماضي، وقد
حققنا نجاحًا في لبنان بعد
الحرب، وحققنا نجاحًا في تلك القضايا الأربع التي
هي في الواقع ذات صلة اليوم بالوضع في
السودان، وقد
عملنا بين
جيبوتي وأه  وإريتريا مع تشاد
وبين الحكومة
والمعارضة ويمكن أن يستمر ذلك
مع هذه الأمثلة ولكن ما
نفعله الآن هو أن إحدى القضايا الرئيسية التي
نعمل عليها الآن هي ديوكسي
ورواندا كما تعلمون أنه كان هناك  هناك
عداء كبير هناك وعلى
المناطق الحدودية ونحن نعمل مع الجانبين
بالتنسيق مع الأمريكيين
للتأكد من أننا نستطيع التوصل إلى نوع من
الاتفاق هناك أه نحن نعمل
مع لبنان الآن لملء الفراغ في
الرئاسة  مقعد آه، كما تعلم، لقد عقدت
اللجنة الحكومية الخمس في الدوحة
اجتماعًا هناك ونحن
نعمل معهم الآن وزير
دولتنا المسؤول عن الوساطة
يأخذ نقطة حول هذا الأمر، ونحن نعمل
في أفغانستان بالطبع وأفغانستان
إنه موضوع مهم للغاية بالنسبة لقطر،
فنحن نستثمر فيه بشكل كبير،
ونحن نعمل في الوساطة بين
أفغانستان وبقية العالم
بشكل أساسي، لذلك هناك الكثير من الأشياء التي يتعين القيام بها ونقول
دائمًا أنك تعلم أنه لا يوجد
سوى على هذه الأرض  340.000 سعرة حرارية، لذا فإن
كل واحد منا لديه ما يقرب من 10 وظائف للقيام بها، وأنت
تعرف الأشياء المختلفة وعندما
يتعلق الأمر بهذه الوساطات، فأنت تعلم أننا جميعًا
نشارك فيها ولكن الأمر
صعب بالتأكيد ولكنه شيء
طبقناه بأنفسنا في قطر
لدفع الأرباح  لأجيالنا القادمة